what I'm thinking about like the kind of  person I want to spend the rest of my  life with I don't want it to be somebody  that I can control I really don't want  it to be in the slightest um I don't  want a man that's controlled by a woman  if you're controlled by a woman then you  can be controlled by the government you  can be controlled by all these other  dangerous things like I'm looking for a  man that's like on his own mission like  uncontrollable he lives on his own path  by his own reality his own morals that's  so important yeah it's super sexy  especially when he has demands of you as  well like you know I'm this kind of man  so I expect you to do these kind of  things and you're just going to be like  okay that makes sense you know